welcome to this video play the Dark
Passenger is there a name nope I have a
bad score three wins five losses yeah
the Queens gambit accepted as recently
sad it's not a bad opening portion 26
schedule this is the latest trend in
this in this line and 2k but it doesn't
seem to be fantastically great for white
but it's difficult anyway to get get
much out of this it is a bit
counterintuitive to trade queens when
you have the IQ p but white has the
better activity and black sometimes
struggles a little bit with coordination
castles rookie one is coming quickly try
to be quick you're not wasting much time
they're very likely it's not so so much
own about a particular move here being
precise you can you can play quickly i
guess i should you 5 195 Bishop g5 I
guess
yeah let's let's get some space here
okay now I guess what you want that is a
very very normal looking move we should
take that six dozen net me much
yeah that looks very solid for black
will be 94 93 I don't know I don't see
something really great seems really
equal
the thing night takes d5 now so I don't
know what he's doing taking 1c3 maybe
well I didn't do is do anything great in
this game I just uh I was a bit quicker
yeah taking them 93 I don't know
yeah it's just equal what can you do
yeah who shakes all porn chicks here
maybe Luke chicks genda cookie 7c 5d 5v5
that could be interesting still I have
from c-5m God ruka if I'm sorry on d5
I've gotta be five yeah so what about
this then
d 5 rupee 8 doesn't help at all maybe I
can do this Bishop g6 like f4
tending at five rupee one I've got ok
this one k attending g4 and h3 is good
okay okay okay and so let's go up here
so king of six not really I mean you can
play king at six there's nothing
particularly bad about it just doesn't
help much or do much check
mm-hmm okay too I guess
that's no way to use this pin really
probably not check anyway it's really
not not a big deal the IQ p.m. and still
equal this position Jay you must place
this rook in such a way that i'm working
in tempted to do something here b6 gh5
kinda taken h5 bc5 take on g6 that's
very close but I mean I don't need to do
anything against his rook is still
completely off no yes this move wow that
is silly but there they let that happen
check check selective no Shaq and we
have absolutely no doubt that this is
still ok check
check check check check check check draw
all check check check check black
forfeits on time not much that I can do
I offered to draw them and it is of
course dad iam I mean now we actually
wins okay but the B point is of course a
total draw the way it was yeah I don't
know hey it was very equal all the way I
had this iqp but you cannot win against
that alone when the defender years
active enough always was active enough i
really wonder if I could have one myself
because putting the rook here looks
ultimately very sick but maybe I really
didn't have anything when the engine
doesn't see anything now then it sends
okay he gets this back into the game and
now he has serious Jen chances I just
hope that i'm still at ganda maybe I was
I mean that doesn't look particularly
great there with the rukon age 6 can I
mean here's extra ponies heaven
chang-keuk a three or so was good yeah
okay that was influenced a lot by there
by the time situation maybe I can still
draw maybe I'm lost
it's a borderline okay well thanks for
watching